In the past few years,
we've seen incredible advances in
artificial intelligence and blockchain
technology that have enabled
a new breed of applications,
decentralized applications
or Dapps for short.
These are open source governed by the
community and crucially profitable for
both the creators and the users.
Open OpenBazaar, for example,
let's buyers and sellers connect with
each other directly with zero restrictions
on trade steam.
It is a decentralized social network
where users get paid for the content.
They post opus let's music creators
keep all of the revenue they earn and
[inaudible] allows its users to earn
money by contributing to a crowd sourced
hedge fund.
This space is just getting started.
A new stack is emerging for developers,
one that will fuel the next
wave of global companies.
Etherium acts as a decentralized
computing platform.
The interplanetary file system has a
decentralized storage network and deep
learning as a layer of intelligence able
to accomplish almost any task if given
the right Dataset.
I'm so Roger Vol and this is the
first course in the school of Ai.
I'll show you how to combine these
technologies together to build your own
decentralized application.
We'll build dapps together that
cover a huge range of use cases from
decentralized gaming to ride
sharing to social networks.
Along the way, you'll have access to
an amazing community of peers, quizzes,
graded projects,
weekly live streams where
I answer questions while
building demos and your own
certificate of completion timestamped
on the blockchain for permanence.
So if you want to be a part of the future
of the web, get hype and sign up today.